Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
The Eggman really is upset with me that I have
been empathetic when it comes to the families
of those who die because they're the families of
those who die, because they are anti vax the kids
of the militia leader who didn't get the
vaccine and died, the kids of the police
captain. If he has kids who didn't get the
vaccine but was on ivermectin and died of covid
a here is the Eggman making a point about
Hitler and empathy. Take a listen to this
Speaker 5: day when Hitler died. Do you
feel bad for his kids, too, you know,
because they're going to grow up fatherless?
Speaker 1: Yeah. So first of all, Eggman,
Hitler had no kids. So, you know, you got to get
your facts straight. I think I get the point that
the egg man is making, like, how bad does the
person have to be before you don't feel bad for
the kids? Now, let me give you a hypothetical. If
Hitler's kids were not lunatic, genocidal Nazis,
then maybe we would feel bad for Hitler's kids if
they're really innocent in the entire thing. As
far as we know, the kids of a lot of these anti
vaccine is as bad as the anti vaccine is as as
weaponized as the disinformation that
the antibiotics are spreading. Might be.
If the kids are just bystanders, why wouldn't
we feel bad for kids that are now going to be
fatherless or motherless? Now, there's a good
chance ultimately the kids would end up being
indoctrinated into the lunatic beliefs of the
parents. That's true. But this is this is actually
a real topic. And I know the argument is I'm not
going to say being facetious, but the argument is
being provocative. There's an article in New York
magazine from a couple of weeks ago called The
Empathy Wars. And it does a pretty good job of
outlining the reality that, as the article says,
we can be mad at the people that are endangering
public health without taking pleasure in their
deaths and while recognizing that their death can
still really negatively affect people in their
lives who may not be purveyors and disseminators
of the misinformation. So just check out the
article, check out the article, The Empathy Wars
in New York magazine from a couple of weeks ago
on today's bonus show, German Chancellor
Angela Merkel is stepping down after 16 years.
What is next for Germany? A court has backed
a teacher refusing to use transgender student
pronouns. What is the legal basis? We will
discuss it. And lastly, the state of Idaho,
very infected state, highly infected state
Idaho is activating the National Guard
over the covid surge that is aggressively taking
place there. All of those stories and more
on today's bonus show. Sign up at Join Pakman
Dotcom to celebrate one billion YouTube views.
You can use the coupon code billions through the
end of the week to get a beautiful discount off
of the membership of your choice at Join Pakman
Dotcom. Also really exciting interview tomorrow.
Vincent Racaniello from the This Week
in Virology podcast will be joining me.
Many of you already sent me questions
for him. If you have other questions,
send them to info at David Pakman Dotcom. We'll
see you on the bonus show. And then, of course,
tomorrow for a great show, including what I
think will be a very interesting interview.